I've been covering basically every one of
these corona virus task force press conferences
live on YouTube, Twitch, Facebook and most
recently livestreaming on Twitter as well.
If you've not been watching them, your mental
state is probably much better than that of
people who have been watching them because
they really are these propaganda explosions.
But I want to highlight two moments that are
just complete microcosms.
Absolutely the epitome of what we're dealing
with here.
Donald Trump, when asked specific questions
about numbers, ventilators, masks, how long
this is all going to go on, when and how many
tests are and will be available.
Trump retreats to vague generalities and weird
statements.
And Trump, during one of the weekend press
conferences, was asked about thermometer availability.
Are they available?
Should they be distributed?
Should people be buying thermometers?
And Trump instead talked about just how stunning
it is that there are infrared thermometers,
not a very new technology, as you may know,
which can take people's temperatures from
a few inches away.
This is what we are dealing with.
The person in charge right now is surprised
and stunned at infrared thermometers.
This is from my stream over the weekend.
So you'll you'll hear me laughing, which is
what I do to avoid crying because of what's
going on.
And I say I've seen things when Tony mentions
the monitors.
They aim something that far ahead.
They say this far away, boom.
And they tell you what your temperature is.
I said, I've never seen that before a lot.
I've learned a lot.
It's a.
Go ahead.
Back corner.
Trump's takeaway from all this is, hey, infrared
thermometers exist.
This guy is operating on a totally different
level than anyone who has any business dealing
with this crisis.
And I don't mean at a higher level, I mean
it at a lower level.
And during the same press conference, Trump
was increasingly tripped up about ventilators.
We have about 170000 ventilators in the entire
country now, somewhere between five and many
more times.
That number of ventilators will likely be
needed during this pandemic.
The U.S. has ventilators in a strategic stockpile.
Trump insists we're getting ventilators, we're
getting people ventilators, we're getting
more ventilators.
We're sending them.
Everybody's going to have them.
Never tells us when.
Never tells us how many.
And Donald Trump here retreated to expressing
shock that, hey, did you know ventilators
are a machine?
Not everybody knows that.
Take a look at this horrifying and sad clip.
You know, a ventilator is a machine.
It's a very complex machine.
And to think that we have to order hundreds
of thousands.
Nobody's ever heard of a thing like this.
You know, when we had in the stockpile, we
had thousands in a stockpile, thousands ready
to go.
That's a lot.
All of a sudden, you need hundreds of thousands.
And you're not talking about.
The mask is whether it's plastic or whether
it's material.
That's one thing.
But you're talking about a very sophisticated,
heavily computerized, machined and delicate
area.
Wait a second.
All this time, ventilators are a machine.
Now adding insult to injury.
Donald Trump said it's a very complicated
machine only to have Mike Pence show up a
minute later and say the opposite.
Mike Pence actually said it's such a simple
machine, not a complicated one, that we're
looking at retrofitting other devices to make
ventilators.
Take a look at this.
It doesn't include what will be produced,
as is the president said.
We're seeing companies step forward with these
manufacturers.
Tell us that a ventilator actually isn't a
very complicated piece of equipment, and many
of them are literally surging forward to create
more ventilators, oŭs.
So it is a very complicated and sophisticated
piece of equipment or it's not.
These are our leaders right now, not by choice.
No Ebola czar.
And of course, we are not in good shape with
these people in charge.
There are so many levels of ugly going on
here.
This is just one of them.
And it's it's truly depressing.